on the show this week the votes are in
you've been helping pick the best
counties of 2014
quizzed on our teenage entrepreneur
in the pocket and an hour getting
through
welcome to wife
cool
cool cool
babbling where you guys have been
talking about tonight lucky enough reply
the Dutton coats
Angela with around after processes 2014
has been an interesting year for gadgets
Apple made its first forays into the
world of wearable tech and finally
revealed a phone with a larger screen
the console wars ramped up as Sony and
Microsoft battled it out for dominance
of gamers hearts minds and fingers and
we've seen a rise in smart devices which
control the technology in your home
while you're out and about but which of
this year's gadgets have come out on top
a panel of expert judges at the Pocket
lint Awards help narrow it down after a
public vote it's been a very tumultuous
year blackberry motorola at nokia have
all had massive changes in the last 12
times but in the court of it that still
being big innovations from all the big
players and some companies you've never
heard of before so what about the
winners apples scooped the top prize
with the iphone 6 winning best phone and
overall gadget of the year demand for a
phone with a larger screen clearly paid
off after seven years in the competition
it's the first time that the iphone has
won sony will also the big winners of
the night scooping four awards including
best compact camera best EV best
headphones and best home entertainment
device with the playstation 4 it tells
us that consumers really do want water
the growth of 4k ultrahigh there we've
seen a growth of high res audio as well
really exciting that one and of course
photography who doesn't want a great
quality so that was 2014 but what can we
expect to see next year 2015 is going to
be quite an exciting year for tech
people one is going to be the inevitable
rise of more wearables and more use case
scenarios for individual wearable
devices the other thing there that I
find more interesting might be smart
textiles which is where the electronics
for various wearable technologies can
actually be woven in and factored inside
garments inside fabrics so whether it's
the growth of smartwatches all the
future of fabric 2015 will have a lot to
offer Angela Barnes Sky News so the
winners have been announced the best
gadgets have been honored for another
year but were you surprised by any of
the results joining me now journalist
Vicki bulletin we'll go another judge I
was quite surprised by the apple iphone
6 taking festival gadget and back phone
having never previously one of the
populism
what changed I mean there's no denying
ourselves well I think what they did is
they found a formula that they liked and
they stop to it and I think what they
did with the iphone 6 is while they were
sticking to this formula Samsung and HTC
were blazing these Thrones and
innovative and they realized whopper you
on a bigger screams all about the solar
guard the big screen but rather than
just releasing the phone that had a
larger screen they actually introduced
tools that we were wanting select
ability for itself makes easier to you
so I think that's been the difference
and also it's really well-made as Apple
always does there's Abduh works now this
time last year a lot of people in the
tech industry we're saying that's why
people thing will be all about wearable
it hasn't quite turned out that way how
that one thing that is I think the media
jump from wearables and I think firms
and start pushing out these devices
without really thinking about what
people wanted and if you think butter
phones a fashion statement its own right
if you're putting something on your
wrist one day it needs to look they all
look good so I think next year my
actually beauty here where wherever that
ok the 2015 could be the year of the way
or anything else expecting 2015 snow
live until now drones have been a bit
need a bit hobbyist I mean that you've
got reports now that goes pro an awesome
so I think 2015 might be a as long as we
can get the legality and the security
you sorted you might see more drones in
the sky right Vicki well it's been great
to talk to you thanks for joining you're
watching flight coming up exploring the
imagius fear with everyone's favorite
and knitted night is a roundup of some
of this week's other text grand theft
auto 5 is the UK's best-selling video
game of all time it follows its recent
release on Xbox one and PlayStation 4
according to gfk chart-track the rock
star and take two title had been just
behind call of duty black ops in the
best sellers race but not anymore here's
some potentially good news for GoPro
fans rumors have it the companies
developing its own helicopter drones
carrying high definition cameras reports
in the Wall Street Journal say the
action camera maker wants to start
selling them towards the end of next
year with prices ranging from around 300
to just over 600 pounds Samsung has come
up with a computer mouse controlled by
your eyes instead of hands the I can
plus allows people with disabilities to
create documents and browse the web by
looking directly at icons and then
blinking Samsung won't be selling it
commercially for the companies do to
make a limited quantity for charities
and a teenager has reinvented the switch
and it could save you money on your
energy bill nineteen-year-old
entrepreneur ya sack attack was studying
for his GCSEs when he came up with the
idea for a system that enables you to
turn off your appliances using a
smartphone app or remote control you can
now turn off all your lights and all
your appliances from the touch of one
button just as you're about to go to bed
or you about to leave the house saving
you money and saving the environment the
UK could save more than a billion pounds
a year by shutting down devices
frequently left on standby yes as
companies using crowdfunding to raise
enough money to bring it to market
and our time for our games review so
while I concentrate on playing Anki
Drive is Kaiser with her pick of the
latest releases this a big planet 3 has
been made by a different studio to the
other two little big planet games on
PlayStation but it hasn't suffered too
much it's a really really fun
multiplayer game multiplayer is
definitely at the heart of Little Big
Planet 3 along with the usual creating
and playing of your own levels it's got
a wonderful aesthetic I still think it's
slightly less good than they for us to a
big planets but if you're looking for
something to play especially with kids
or friends with four players it's really
good on that front so minecraft is the
biggest game in the world it's
unsurprising that it was going to come
to xbox one but we've waited over a year
since the consoles released for it to
arrive the benefits it has over the
minecraft you might have played on the
Xbox 360s it's just got much much bigger
worlds that's basically why you want to
play it for Minecraft obsessives if
you've been playing minecraft for the
last several years it's not going to
have changed much but the great thing
about that game is that it you just
never run out of things to do
the newest Pokemon game is actually a
remake of a Pokemon game from the early
2000s Ruby and Sapphire it's got the
same monsters that's got roughly the
same world but it's much much better
it's got loads of features from newer
pokemon games that make it much easier
more fun to play one thing I'd say about
it is if you have ever played a Pokemon
before you know exactly what to expect
from this it's not particularly
innovative and it doesn't surprise you
very often it's not enormously
challenging but it's still just
absolutely brilliantly made and I think
the competitive see with Pokemon and the
next year is going to benefit enormously
from some of the changes that it's made
to the basics of constipating Smash Bros
Wii U is kind of like Mario Kart except
with punching there's a ridiculous
number of Nintendo characters from the
most obscure games when way back in the
data than most kind of relevant you once
you've also got pac-man and Sonic
joining the fight essentially it's
really really fun especially with other
people in the same room there's a
version I on 3ds but the wii u version
has 8 player fighting it's got better
online and it's generally more fully
featured it's going to be the game I'm
playing with my friends for the next
several months don't forget to stay out
today all week with the latest ektoras
on Chinese I